hi my name is Matthew I work at NetFlow
and I've been there for about two years
and since I joined it kind of worked on
this project I'm gonna describe some of
the tools to do all the stuff I'm gonna
show is all open-source accessible so
other than like how we use it like all
the pieces you see you can go find and
reuse yourself so I work on the big data
and big data platform team which is
basically works on back-end tooling to
help support other teams particularly
we're on the orchestration team so we
deal with scheduling work and you'll see
why that relates this in a second you
got my info up there last time I like
didn't check my Twitter for like a week
after I did the talk and then a bunch of
you'll ask me questions I'll be better
this time so so one thing I get asked a
lot when I used to give you know
conversations about what I do is okay
well what does the data platform even do
what's that job and this is important to
set context for like how we use this and
why so here's kind of like if you think
about like an end like you have data
input some different sources from users
events system metrics whatever else you
get your your data from and most
people's jobs are actually to just you
know convert that date with some outcome
a report a data model tell somebody
yes/no on a business decision but to do
that job is kind of hard that's why
we're all here and the data platform
team tries to make that easier for
people so we're like an adjacent team of
many people who try to build tools to
make ETL and machine learning easier to
do so you don't have to think about the
low-level things or the integration
parts as much and you can think more
about what your actual job is so the
open source projects I'm going to talk
about today cover and earn Jupiter and
interact or the orgs that have them
interact is just kind of like a branch
of projects which add some extra flavor
things into Jupiter and has some time
experimentation modules for different
ways to approach Jupiter notebooks and
myself and so my colleagues contribute
to all these projects I'm on the Jupiter
core team and interact I would guess a
development group as well and we do open
Lots open source communications so if
you want to get involved with those
groups it's really easy just reach out I
can help point
right direction all right show of hands
how many of you know what the
differencing of Jupiter notebook is and
a Zeppelin notebook yeah I don't think
I've ever had more than like 5% or 10%
of the room raise our hand so let's not
quickly briefly about what a jupiter
notebook is so this is like the classic
Jupiter UI you see like as these cells
and basically what that is is the
Jupiter is a an ecosystem of tools that
allows you to execute program Attica Lee
executes this kind of repple based code
so it's a collection of cells and each
of the cells have code or texts or
displays in them that then you can
execute to render a result and those
kind of like you can run them linearly
in Jupiter you can run them nonlinearly
which sometimes gets people in the
trouble and that will save a file and
Jupiter all of that works through a
protocol pattern so Jupiter has this
like API spec that the backend and the
front-end are isolated from so when you
do an execute call you're actually are
sending a message to execute some code
and it's almost like you were typing on
a repple execute this code though other
notebook systems are more integrated so
they'll be more like the execute and the
front-end are all coupled together in
one toolset so Jupiter is more
extensible but it does mean it's a
little more complicated which some
people I'm getting into it but it means
it's much easier to build extensions
others can use inside of it which is why
we kind of dived really heavily in the
Jupiter yuko system back a few years ago
all right I can't talk about some of
this but like what is it kind of why
would you use a notebook or what's in it
well you think of it like rendered
repple where you have a command-line
interface you would type some code here
you have your code your logs the
documentation about your logs and the
execution results can all in one
document it gets saved as one object
it's visible as one object in your
browser or in other renderings mediums
and it's really useful for iterative
development for sharing results of what
you did and for integrating various API
calls so like on the right is like an
example you load some data you do some
model iteration my fact I think all the
talks I've seen today have a Jupiter
notebook like running whatever example
they have so it's really good for talks
and things like that and you can't
display results and you don't have to
change pages you have to like jump
between different codes great
so you can kind just I'll show at one
place a little bit if you've never used
them before there's a couple like useful
feet you see there's usually on whatever
UI you're looking at there's a status
save indicator about how off recently
it's saved there's a code cell which has
the code you actually on to execute and
a block that you would run at one time
there's usually an output section
displayed below about text the logs and
the visualizations and you know it makes
it very easy to share it's easy to read
you get documentation with code you has
a lot of like nice advantages it's also
multi-language so that's one of the
differences between Jupiter and other
systems in some ways is Jupiter defines
a kernel spec actually isn't specific to
Python even though python has the best
integration with it so there's lots of
kernels or other languages there's even
like some new ones like some c-sharp
ones they're out there now and Scala and
some others are getting some better ones
too
and how's this actually execute is
important but if you think about it from
like kind of what's doing what your user
as a user seeing firm computer or you're
basically talking to this Jupiter UI
there's many different Jupiter you eyes
because it's an API protocol you can
implement your own so there's many out
there and that's gonna talk back to some
server that you know host those api's
and respond to them and reflects the
requests an actual execution and then
the that's gonna save your result to
some file that's usually an IP myb
extension and it afforded quests the
same called Jupiter kernel and the
kernel is actually the thing that does
the computation it knows how to actually
execute the commands in that language or
that framework so if you have a ipython
kernel it is the thing that hosts a
Python process and the kind of kernel
receiving endpoint that will take the
execute request
it'll take the like what can I call
requests and things like that and
translate to a JSON request response
back and forth all right so we're some
of the use cases for notebooks and we'll
get into this why it kind of expanded
from where it started for a start it's
kind of like exploring and prototyping a
day scientists you oftentimes have very
expensive computation needs to do and
you don't know what you need to compute
after that so you know books are good
because you can take a cell collect all
the data you need and then try something
on the next cell
and try again and again and again
without having to recompute everything
beforehand so helps you're kind of a dev
lifecycle go a lot faster when you're
exploring something this means you have
quick iteration cycles expensive queries
you can do once you can record the
outcomes and it's kind of easy to modify
it in place and you kind of get your job
done without thinking about how long is
it gonna take for the download that gig
again but it's not all good there's
trade-offs to this working environment
which had a lot of kick back I think
initially when notebooks got introduced
outside of the science community there
they have a lack of history so like if I
save the notebook and make a change
save the notebook and I forgot what I
changed you might be out of luck
they're little difficult to test so
there's not a place to put a unit test
so Nona productionize things use time I
was get some friction about how do i
productionize this notebook so it can
actually be reliable and other people
could use it the document is mutable so
you're always not like a immutable
record there's some tooling that helps
with these things but this is like the
state of the world maybe a year ago
there were two years and it's hard to
prioritize and live collaboration just
don't do it it doesn't work they're the
only tool that really does it right is
collab or are not collab what's that no
collab took it away collab used to have
it and then there's a academic tool that
I'm blanking on the name of Co calc
alright so paper mill was actually
managed to try and fill some of these
like negative gaps so this is a library
and when we started working on this we
kind of wanted to preserve the good
things and improve some of the not good
things so we want to preserve the
results linked the code so you wanted to
have like what happened right next to
the code that executed it and know those
things together you want the
visualizations there as well you know I
think you're really easy to share your
results so if I run a notebook I want to
give the resulting outcome to somebody
so they could either be executed or view
it or see what I did the things want to
improve we're notebook smart versioned
so we wanted to kind of introduce
something with help with that the
mutable state problem where your
notebook was mutable so you never really
knew what you actually did when that
outcome was produced and we wanted to
help make them template rules so I can
make one
mark notebook and I can just tweak it a
little bit about rewriting the notebook
in order to execute many different like
spark jobs or something like that so we
made this library called paper Melanie
interact org and affect what paper mill
does is it takes a notebook as an input
it parameter eise's it with a set of
JSON parameters and then it runs that
notebook monitor is the execution just
like a run all cells would in your UI
and then it stores that to a different
place so you can specify the output
location independent of the input
location and so you'll get kind of a
direct record of what happened in that
one run as a back-end executable you
don't need a UI or front-end or any
JavaScript to actually execute the
notebook in this case you can run all
purely in the paper mode Python library
so what's this kind of look like in
Python we're gonna show a little bit of
code okay I'm gonna see that pretty well
it's okay alright good
so here it's actually really simple
interface you import papermill you do
this dot execute notebook you pass in
the input and the output and in this
most simple case you will run that and
produce an outcome so here you can see
maybe I would be iterating through days
I've on a run and I run the input
notebook and just say the day I want
that I ran it for is the name and the
really simplest way to sort of give a
per day execution version and then I put
that someplace and if I listed all the
files in that directory you know I would
see that I have a run for each day and I
could kind of just see what happened if
you wanted to parameterize a notebook
say you have this run but you really
want to like give us some inputs the
Naro what it's executing maybe it does
something like I don't count the number
of viewers on different devices in some
region so you can specify Oh filter
there just California and only do phones
and tablets I want to know about those
instead of other things then you can
pass this as a parameters and they will
be mapped into the notebook without
actually do inside the notebook is that
JSON we converted the code so below you
would see what if I had this kind of a
default value in the cell number two
marked as two with a region us and
device PC and some deep calculation I
did when I do the execute notebook it's
gonna inject another cell after that one
that was tagged as a parameter cell and
to convert your JSON into code of region
equals California device equals a list
the phone tablet so it can convert any
JSON into the language code of your
kernel and then when you execute that
notebook it just happens to be right
after the default values and so it'll
overwrite them where they need to be and
that's how it actually parameters Rises
all right so you can also this from a
CLI which is actually how it's most
commonly used if you're not writing
extensions you can write the Xu notebook
it from Python you can also just use the
CLI and say papermill and give the input
output and then your standard kind of
command are options for all the things
you could pass in to execute notebook
here we do dash p for a primitive
parameter - y for passing gamma which is
a superset of json so you usually just
use that the passage ace on blob of
whatever you want to pass into the
notebook all right let's hope the
Internet let's display cool so you can
see when you're running the CLI I mean
some project I have this notebook basics
IBM IV file I can just say paper mill
and be basics and execute this and then
you'll see how it actually works by
default you can control a lot of the
outputs and what it logs to the command
line there's lots of options there but
here by default it's gonna kind of do a
progress bar and tell you what the input
and output paths are gonna be kind of as
more informative for a human you can
change this to be more machine readable
if you want and if you pass parameters
you can just you know to say we want to
set the conference to be PyCon you tell
when I made this video and yeah so it
rerun the same one it added an extra
parameter so because you pass parameters
so now there's two different outputs the
first time I ran and the second one with
our extra parameter has different
outcomes and we can go read those files
independently and the input wasn't
touched if we do something very quit
with Python it looks very similar so say
I have a notebook here it this is the
notebook I'm actually going to execute
it has an image that it prints called
the papermill logo and it adds some
strings together to see how you spell
papermill very complicated example
and if you just run the important paper
mill execute notebook it's gonna look
very similar and it has nice notebook
support so it gives a nice like rendered
bar they actually updates in place and
then you can do the same passing
parameters it works all the same way so
it's a very simple interface to use it's
meant to be very like easy to drop in
and just replace an execution much like
you would execute a script was saying
Python script and then passing the args
and that'd be the outcome so you see we
injected this mill equals mill too and
it does paper plus mill became paper
mill too so how does this change the
kind of paradigm of X Kenya notebook
which used to always be back many years
ago just running from a server well now
we can actually run we can read in the
notebook instead of a UI running the
execution management paper mill is
managing the execution and it's writing
to a unique output instead of writing in
place but under the hood it uses a
kernel manager the same way the
jupiter's server would and it talks to
the same exact kernel in the same exact
way so from an execution and back-end
point of view it's executing just like a
user opened up a notebook server and
said run all and and then the only
difference being that we capture the
output and put it someplace else instead
of mutating in place a little more
detail if you don't see like what that
actually looks like internally the code
base isn't very deep if you read it's
only like a couple thousand lines of
code and almost all of that is actually
connecting to other resource locations
like s3 in Azure and things like that so
here you see we have like the notebook
source and parameters the inputs to our
paper map function the runtime managers
it's basically initiated by paper mill
which actually exports that to from
another library already had to
implemented and then it may monitors the
runtime process and kind of extends the
other default behavior for some paper
and specific things like injecting in
metadata about the execution time and
errors and catching them and doing kind
of quality of life improvements on on
the results and the other thing you do
here which I haven't talked about much
yet is your sources and your sinks can
be basically anything so you can
register schemes with papermill you
don't by writing an extension and then
it it will be able to
from that scheming poll from our DS's or
from s3 or from Azir from some other
exotic place and it can also write to
those places so you can basically give
it a pass that let you look in deeper to
other systems you already have without
having to like manage copying files from
your other system into your local and
context some of these that are built-in
by default or Google Cloud is your s3 I
think there's one or two more now these
days it's really easy to add so if you
have another one you want to add it's
quick to add a PR and extending it's
super super easy everything in the whole
repo is plug and play let's say we
wanted to add SFTP this is all you need
so you make your SFTP handler with a
read function and a write function has
to have that signature you then in your
own project you don't have to do it in
paper mill you use the entry points you
set up tools and you add an entry point
and you just register this paper mill IO
you register the scheme on the left and
you put the class name that you're gonna
use for that scheme and then you can
then use it inside anything that has
that package installed and now SFTP
works for input/output so all right so
you know given this is the library and
the tool and how is it how do you use
this to production-wise notebooks and
one even you think about when you're
using this tool to kind of use a real
business use case so notebooks in
production is kind of a sticky topic
there's ways to do it that let you in
trouble which are really obvious because
there's this mutable state object it's
highly shareable it's not necessarily
controlled in version control by default
so there's some things you'll want to
kind of do above and beyond what
notebooks give you out of the box the
sort of kind of use them in production
and there's a number of companies doing
this now so it's not just Netflix these
days so like I kind of tried to boil
down some of the learnings in the past
couple years of what people have done
and what what has helped make
operationally smooth process so
definitely add markdown comest sell to
the top of your notebook explain what
the notebook does how it works there's
something complicated put a markdown
cell in there make a nice little
document inside your xq
so when someone else reads it they know
what's going on without having to leave
and go someplace else
right did an integrity notebook or a
cell possibly if you don't want to write
a whole another data check when you're
doing ETL I can't stress enough like
auditing your data is super super
important it isn't any different when
you're using a notebook versus using a
script or a sequel statement to do that
execution you still want to audit your
data notebooks do give you the
opportunity to audit within the notebook
though we tend to not do that very much
because you couple the ideas together so
it's hard to restart just the audit part
automatically so we oftentimes build
workflows where the first part does a
notebook that executes something and
later is something audits with either a
notebook or some other tool to get check
the data integrity before it releases
that data to everyone else and writing
an integration test or three is a really
good idea
so notebooks actually really easy the
integration test they're just hard the
unit tests so if you think about a
notebook as a good way to write an
integration tool and you write tests
against that integration you can
actually a pretty high reliability
that's gonna be working as expected
also we know with writing is
integrationist I put all these things
into your git repo put your notebook
integration test and any skit like
schedule definitions put them all as
close as you can to gather in the same
repo it helps the colocation of like
what you're doing how you're doing it
and how you prove it's right we tried to
emphasize this so we made our scheduler
have a declarative definition with the
amyl of how to specify your how to
schedule this thing and your notebook is
right next to it and your tests right
next to it so put things together and
also like reference the SHA that you
executed when you do things and that can
be really valuable for kind of audit
traceability and you'll make a lot of
your system platform data and data
engineer tool teams a lot happier
speaking as one of those tool teams um
you definitely want to also like set up
CI tools and builds most ETL pipe ones
already have these it's really easy to
add another one we literally just added
a runner which said run papermill on a
notebook and that notebook happens to be
a test against the other notebook so you
can kind of set something up where I'm
gonna do the runner as though if I were
system or user executing this template
or this ETL code I've written
but I'm gonna parameterize it to put
things into a dummy place so we'll run
all of our templates and all of our code
that we can or write it to the m-seal
database instead of the you know prod
database and then check that the data
there the scene and prove that you're
kind of end end integration works that
saves you a lot of pain it won't save
you for like little data errors you
might have at runtime but there's other
solutions for that that are more ETL
based and less on the execution
framework I can talk about more of those
after the talk if you want to come find
me Oh last thing too is really handy to
save your paper Mel outputs that you do
to someplace that's automatically
accessible to your users so either
landing it in there mounted file share
so they can get to them or to wherever
their notebook server is or even better
we map it to s3 and input view only
render on top of that so that the users
can see what the results were without
being able to edit it easily or at all
so that way they can see what happened
without touching the actual execution
and then we let them copy that to their
workspace so you always get copies of
things and the notebooks are always even
beautiful everywhere that helps a lot
with physical that's probably the number
one thing people have appreciated in
using notebooks in our ecosystem is the
fact that there's immutable records and
what happened and I can just click a
button to copy and rerun and they rerun
it in my local dev and I don't have to
ask anyone as a developer how do I
reproduce what went wrong it you know
1:00 in the morning the other thing has
been really valuable we've had a lot of
positive outcomes from is template izing
the common patterns so let people write
their notebooks and if they're
scheduling them if you see common ones
or ones people do a lot try to trains
like bring that into a central team and
have them like build up like
professional version of that or a shared
version of that
so make templatized patterns make that
easy for people to add at this point now
we have like a half dozen teams
contributing new templates all the time
down to our central place where we have
the like bless'd templates that people
can pull in and we automate more and
more things around it so we pull
documentation automatically from them to
generate our Doc's we put all our tools
like know what notebooks are in that
repo and automatically build bindings to
like just reference I want to run they
presto job well you just have to say
tight press though and we know there's a
presto notebook that does that
and then also a fun thing you can do is
if you tag cells you can add cell tags
and that's really handy for kind of
convention based like self-documenting
so we'll do things like if you want to
have something that makes it to the
auto-generated Docs just add this tag to
a cell and we'll put it in the docs I
automatically so you just write your
Doc's in your notebook and we'll put it
so that's visible on the kind of guided
tour all right so if you want to see
what one of these templates look like I
domed one down a little bit to remove
the internal imports that don't matter
to you but this is like 80% of what our
actual template is for running SPARC one
thing you'll notice is that we didn't
actually put any real logic in here this
is like very much a template to
integrate and just says like here I give
me the inputs I will apply them in some
ski Midway I'll maybe do some a search
for things that should be there and I'll
give you nice in your messages if you
have the wrong thing and then I put all
the complexity in a library down below
so we have this spark submit job class
that kind of knows how to translate
arguments to the actual spark cluster
and the users don't need to know that
and so we make that oh that's a well
supported library that was already there
we just built a template to integrate
with that library in a nice way and at
the bottom we kind of split cells for
like 1 to initialize the job so it
prints out what the job shape is going
to be and then one to say what's when
execution starts that it started and
what status is and then the final one
when it's all done print what the final
outcome was and we kind of just pull
until we get there it's really handy you
can kind of see incremental e as it's
going and even while it's executing
you'll still get saves as every cell
completes to the output location of the
notebook I've kind of hinted at this but
notebooks you probably shouldn't think
about them as libraries which i think is
a common mistake that's been made if
your notebook is many pages long and has
many different functions in it it might
not be a good candidate for scheduling
or automating it might be a good
exploration for what you want in your
library so treat treat notebooks where
they really shine in a production
setting as an integration tool if you
have it as a library may be used as a
learning for what you should bundle
together and something is versioned and
packaged notebooks haven't solved that
problem I don't know if they're aiming
to
just something if you avoid doing that
you'll save yourself a lot of pain and
it's not too hard usually your team
already has a packaging solution for
those types of things and usually it's
shared code it puts you through some
rigor to write some unit tests and some
other things that are probably a good
idea for anything that's worth sharing
yeah so they're unreliable when they get
really complex because you know if you
don't have unit tests on those functions
you know how they're gonna behave is
gonna be more unpredictable the more you
have some development guys fall into
that creep the low brant branching
factor the simple better and keep the
one primary outcome another common
mistake the hop is we'll have one
notebook that builds the feature model
like does the looping over all the
possible features does out a shell
process
comes back builds a data model runs that
data model on production data against
ten tables and then prints out the
result of all of them right that might
be a good and then experiment but you
don't want to schedule that because how
can you you can't run individual parts
easily and use it on the whole thing and
the end would be kind of a monster and
it makes it really hard for someone else
to adopt it like if I look at a notebook
and it's got 50 cells in it I'm gonna be
like well just tell me what this does
cuz I'm not gonna read it and your
co-workers that come in are gonna do too
so be nice to your co-workers and try to
follow these alright so no books and
DAGs this is how we also kind of apply a
lot of value you know if you're gonna
break up these really complex notebooks
and the units of work that make sense
much like you would like a function or a
library service you need to be able to
iterate over them so if you're doing
that same fan-out or some parameter they
were just talking about you might have a
notebook which sets up the initial data
of what you're gonna fan out over or
does some prep work and then you might
fan and do some repeated work over and
over over again so you can use things to
build and do a dag and execute a dag
lots of schedulers do this so open
source tools like airflow and like
old-school like ooze e all those things
will let you do these types of patterns
and then you can execute those and what
we actually have done this we've made
every one of those nodes just into a
notebook and so the outcome the user can
always see the result as going to the
notebook link they never have to know
what type of job it is they can always
go to that notebook you know if you were
to do this in an ETL what would ETL be
in the space you would maybe have like a
dimension
table insert and then you need to update
everyone who is downstream in that
dimension table maybe you would iterate
through you know the partitions of some
table that need to be updated and I
would say for each of those I'm gonna do
the fact join against the dimension
table and like build the new partition
with the updated information and there I
can like fan it out and if one of these
fails I can just isolate work on its own
and I have a notebook that told me how
it failed I could even test out locally
until I got it right and then rerun it
and that's a really handy like usability
tool to pull out when the user wants to
know like well this failed in today's
world before without like a central
template that's easy to reproduce when
something fails I won't always have to
get support so if that fails it like
3:00 in the morning you have to page
someone they have to wake up they have
to think like actually wake up and
figure out what the problem is help you
reproduce the issue or isolate the
problem or tell you what you need to do
so this saves a ton of ton of time for
us I have time time for our users and
makes kind of for some better like
smooth ETL pipelines so show you
something like how we do you know if you
want to do testing on a notebook so
we'll do like controlled integration
tests where you know we're gonna run our
template and we're gonna see you know
how many users we have on Luna which by
the way is a pretty small number
I hope it's zero might not be maybe that
uh crashed moon rover is sending
messages so you gonna do some fake data
some fake regen give a fake date and you
oftentimes will do things like add a
debug true or dry run flag into these
templates so it's really easy to kind of
run and see what it would have done
without actually doing anything and then
basically this would be the same
template user running production but
here the parameters get injected are
very you know specific to this debug and
then we kind of feel outcome like what
would be the sequel you would run
instead of actually running or run it
where we're targeting dummy data that we
know won't hurt anyone if you do
something bad and you can just basically
write that and produce an outcome so I
talked a little bit failed notebooks
fail notebooks are really key because
they're actually a very useful unit of
work about what happened and a record of
truth of the execution someone can go
back and reference that over and over
and over again they don't have to worry
about logs are going to be scraped up or
deleted or move to no
place it's all collected in one place if
you log your outcomes in it and that one
object is like a very good source of
truth for what happened so I say like
one of the big value ads here is not the
happy path but the unhappy path in your
kind of eto it helps kind of smooth that
over and let your users be more self
productive I kind of talked about this
um but like you get stack traces the
code segments that can be regrettable
the execution logs are even better than
logs and files because they're broken
down by what cell created them so if I
have like 10 cells they're doing things
I can jump straight to the cell it fails
and just read the log so that self first
and just see the stack trace for that
part know the scan thousands of lines
until I find the log that was associated
with the thing that failed that kind of
save some time for like he's a mental
exercise of finding royal enroll and so
oftentimes our users will go find the
issue they'll test the fix by cloning a
notebook tweaking whatever the input
parameter was that was wrong or the code
execution that was wrong
try running in their dev environment
prove it works maybe even hotfix the
data right there and then when they've
got it all right they will you know
check that change back into their repo
or their schedule and kind of move on
with life and not have to involve very
many teams so we basically add notebook
isolation with immutable inputs util
outputs parameterization and notebook
runs and then configurable sourcing and
sinking and this just gives a lot better
control flow for notebooks as like cells
to execute you're actually ETL work and
we've had a lot of success with this I
think it's been like valuable these are
the things that were good they came out
of it we tried many things some of the
others were maybe not as good or are
more specialized there's lots of other
ecosystem goodies I'm not gonna go
through these right now they're in the
slides and also if you go to those open
source projects can see lawsone there's
tons and tons of other tools to help
solve the micro problems a rat notebook
ecosystem there's env convert which
actually is the engine that runs paper
mill execution above computers a
read-only render bookstore is s3
persistence for your checkpoints when
you're doing live dubbing all those type
things and some of these I'll leave the
slides here I'm gonna lightning talk I
think later on scrapbook so I'll skip
over that and show you it later and
commuters are read-only interfere
it's a little bit note the like to
companies that are using this very
heavily have branched away from the open
source one so it does need some love of
somebody wants to kind of try and help
come back in and update that to keep it
up to date and have nicer features that
would be awesome
and one final note for our go to
questions if you think like it's this
paper where is it really being used we
move all the ETL at Netflix onto this
pattern so like there are tens of
thousands of jobs that run every day
and those tens of thousands of ETL batch
jobs all run on top of notebooks even if
the user isn't aware of that anymore
because if they use one of our notebook
templates or they use own custom
notebook we're able to bring users who
we're developing notebooks closer to the
existing map rewriting code and we were
able to get everyone else into the same
pattern and now everyone expects it to
be a notebook link when something fails
so they can go look at what happened we
made it more consistent for all our
users and it's worked out really well so
at least for us this was a success
awesome
so I think it we got about like five
minutes for questions because the by
default almost all the tools pretty
print the JSON so the diffing are the
question by the way was when you're
saving to github and you get diffing on
your source of truth what do you
actually see with notebooks between two
changes and the answer is because it get
pretty prints the diff actually looks
okay you still have to read JSON though
especially if it's lots of changes so
there's some other tools MB dime has a
differ an MB viewer has a plugin for
github that's really nice and there's a
couple other options out there now stash
there's a little bit bucket a little
further behind but they just made an API
change like a month ago or so that
allows for that same diffing in stash
just no one's done the integration yet
so that that story is getting better can
you take two notebooks as inputs and
the question was can we take two
notebooks and stitch them together as an
input no if you wanted to do that you
would have to do your own custom logic
the tooling is there to do that if you
know what the business logic is but
generally we try to keep it simple
stupid so that you can't make as many
self-inflicting wounds find the first
cell that has these three inputs and
parameterize them right below that what
about the right variables and things
like that yes the parameter the question
was how smart is the parameterization is
it just put at the top or is it try to
be really intelligent it's pretty dumb
what it looks for is the rule is if it
finds a the first cell that has the
parameter tag in it it will inject the
parameters in the next cell it will not
check what they are it doesn't know if
you did anything else so it's up to you
to make sure you're aligning those two
up yes so one who's around derived
variables probably want to do derive
burials in a cell below your parameter
cells so that you overwrite the default
base raw values before you do the derive
computations yeah that's usually what we
do you saw in there we had like spark
pulling out the script below in a
different cell can you suppress code one
generating outputs can you suppress code
when generating outputs yes there's a
few report you could do - report mode
when you execute and that will hide
it'll not all you eyes respect it but
most of them do now and if they don't
they'll catch up except maybe classic
they'll hide the code cells so there's a
tag that hide the coat the input or the
output it'll probably be more
standardized next year there's like
three metadata tags different people
came up with but there's some push to
combine them - hash report mode
the question was when using cloud binary
integration does paper mail do the
pickling so paper mill verbatim just
send the JSON document it doesn't do
anything else so whatever is in the JSON
document that would have been saved if
you did ctrl s that's what it's sending
so if you've data you're saving you do
want to like save that someplace I would
also be one thing I didn't warn about
scrapbook is a repo to try and help with
this
but don't save really really big
outcomes in your output of your cells
because that makes the JSON document
very big and JSON it's not exactly the
most compressed format so if you get too
big like above tens of megabytes
you'll start crashing browsers
realistically you can get higher than
that but on lower end machines you'll
crash the browser papermill will be fine
though yes so the question was is this
maybe not a good choice for jobs and
reduce loss a heavy graphical output if
you have really giant graphs you're
rendering in a lot of places you
probably want to think carefully about
that or yeah possibly not use the tool
for that specifically but many times you
might be running into the single outcome
rule that I put in there because if
you're making many many graphs then
maybe you're visualizing too many
outcomes in one place so if you broke it
up a bit more that might be a way to
approach it
though most visualizations aren't too
bad they're not that big actually if you
had a ton of them you would get to that
size but most of the time like you're
doing a matplotlib they don't take very
much space
do you guys use this internally as like
a replacement can you or do you use it
for a replacement for daily reporting
like a Domo dashboard or a tableau or
anything like that yeah so um in that
sense some teams do not everyone there
was an effort maybe two years ago to go
in that direction and start implementing
it and then there was kind of a reorg
and repair atari prioritization
internally for us so it stopped kind of
pushing on that effort but some teams
still went with that even without us
pushing it can be used for that I would
say you need some quality of life on
some of the UI's to make that nice so
like the hiding inputs and some of the
other things interact was an attempt to
build components to build you eyes to do
that so there are some companies using
the interact front-end components to
build reporting you eyes out of
notebooks so the notebook will land in
that and they'll choose what the render
and whatnot and use the components there
so unless an app developer build
something around it for simple things
like it's just for me or a few people or
I don't care if it's not the most
perfect representation it is a very
quick way to do a report I would say are
like machine learning is much more like
users are much more likely to build a
report in notebooks because they know
them the users who are in tableau just
already do tableau and M alt learn
something new so they're you'd have to
kind of do a push if they already in an
existing tool but if otherwise yes it
does work and some percentage of our
users do use it that way all right
well thank you very much Matthew yeah I
appreciate it